henry cavill's good looks and strong
voice make him a natural fit to play
superman but getting into god-like shape
to play the last son of krypton is a
superhuman feat in and of itself how
exactly did cavill make himself faster
than a speeding bullet and more powerful
than a locomotive let's find out
exclusive jim
in order to turn himself into the man of
steel henry cavill turned to the
exclusive jim jones an invite-only gym
known for training athletes military
personnel and the cast of 300. jim jones
is not your warm and cozy neighborhood
pilates studio the gym prides itself on
having no televisions and no machines
and no mirrors and no comfortable places
to sit and apparently their walls have
seen a fair share of breakdowns both
physical and psychological
pushing limits
cavill's training regimen essentially
pushed him into the realm of the
superhuman he explained i'm training two
and a half hours a day pushing my body
beyond its normal limits it's not just a
physical thing but a psychological thing
as well cavalry called to shortlist one
particularly excruciating moment with
his trainer mark twight during which
cavil said he was doing some horrible
rowing sprint thing and i said i can't
do this mark i can't i'm done and he
said no you're not don't listen to the
lies i kept on pulling and pulling until
suddenly i realized i'd finished
strong foundation
getting big is one thing staying
superman sized however is an entirely
different story
yeah well you know got to up the game
every year
henry cavill's twice daily training
sessions may have helped him get jacked
but once filming actually started that
regimen went out the window still the
man of steel was able to minimize the
detrimental effects of a reduced to
workout regimen thanks to the ultra
solid muscle base it built dwight
explained stable fitness requires a
wider solid foundation the deeper that
foundation the more stable that
condition will be and the easier it is
to maintain
catching these before cavill even
started training twice laid down one
extremely important stipulation the
actor needed to get nine to ten hours of
sleep every single night for five months
twice explained to muscle and fitness if
you don't get the sleep if you can't
recover then we can't continue with this
training and we won't achieve the
objective the hgh and testosterone
secretion that happens during these deep
sleep cycles is super important
the tailpipe gavel's trainer highly
recommends ending any superman workout
with something he likes to call the
tailpipe which was given its name
because as twight says quote when you're
done it feels like you've been sucking
on the tailpipe of a car basically you
rode 250 meters at full speed then hold
two 24 kilogram kettlebells in the rack
position and repeat three times after
that your lungs will certainly feel the
burn and you'll be able to get more out
of each subsequent workout thanks to the
increased lung capacity and stamina
can't skip cardio many people looking to
bulk up don't get in enough cardio which
does a lot more than just make you
faster than a speeding bullet cavill
strength coach michael blevins explained
to men's fitness there's a misconception
that cardio will negatively impact
muscle a larger work capacity can allow
you to train harder and longer building
muscle without conditioning is akin to
having an impressive engine without a
gas tank it's worthless
brazilian jujitsu
one of caval's favorite ways to stay in
shape is by practicing brazilian jiu
jitsu however the actor doesn't just
dabble in the martial art he trains with
the best caval frequently takes lessons
from ten time jujitsu world champion
hodger gracey in an instagram post he
wrote my bjj has slipped by the wayside
a bit with my focus being on work but
it's now time to get back into it such
an enjoyable way to train
chow down
while training to become superman cavill
would generally eat between 3 500 and 5
000 calories per day including regular
post-workout shakes he explained you've
got to eat protein first then a little
bit of carbs you've got to keep your
hunger levels going unfortunately a
guinness is what i crave so it's not
ideal for the six-pack abs getting
thousand calories meant roughly six
meals per day henry cavill.org list
samples of the 3 500 and 5 000 calorie
meal plans on their man of steel
workouts and diet page
strength of character anyone can hire
some skilled personal trainers and put
down a bunch of calories to get ripped
but playing superman requires more than
simply lifting heavy objects and
exhibiting lightning speed being
superman requires inner strength dwight
told muscle and fitness genuine
accomplishment looks and feels different
it cannot be faked by doing physically
difficult things by changing his body of
his own will henry changed his attitude
and his bearing he looked huge he walked
huge his attitude broadcast his physical
capability
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too